if you were kidnapped and forced to play
a deadly game where only the most
ruthless people survive what would you
do an entire island full of killers is
out to get you and you'll have to use
your gamer knowledge to escape in one
piece i'm here to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the bomb game in batoon this
teenager's dreams of being the best in
the world is going to end up costing him
his life sakamoto here is one of the
best gamers in the whole of japan he
plays the video game platoon a
third-person shooter with bombs as the
primary means of attack as well as sonar
to find enemies around the map he takes
everyone out with ease like the armchair
warrior that he is and figures that he
needs to test his skills on a worldwide
scale however in the real world sakamoto
is a loser and has no life one day he
wakes up in a forest and is confused how
he got there the night before he was
playing patoom as usual and has no
memory of leaving his house he opens his
phone to find out that he has no service
that's when he looks at his hand and
finds a glass shard embedded inside
noticing a bag on the ground he opens it
to find his wallet and the items he
bought from the convenience store the
night before sakamoto makes his way
through the forest and onto a beachfront
suddenly he now realizes that he's a
long way from home he sits down on the
beach and finds a strange-looking item
in his bag with a timer throwing it
before it hits zero the item turns out
to be a bomb just like in his video game
at night he notices another person off
in the distance he waves to the stranger
when suddenly the silhouette comes
rushing towards him with killer intent
sakamoto realizes that the man looks
exactly like an enemy in batoon and runs
off okay this is insane because just
like if you threw a call of duty
champion player into real life basic
training it's pretty obvious that
sakamoto will likely suck at anything
physically tough unless he's a gamer and
a gym rat and based on what we saw he
isn't and based on this encounter with
these crazy bastards it means that it's
pretty clear that we're somehow stuck in
a world just like our video game while
we may not be physically up to par with
what horrors await us in this world we
do have some advantages that we could
use in a way we've been training for
this day our entire lives because
sakamoto is not just an avid player of
batoon he is a video game champion which
means that he's the best of the best at
something to do with the platoon game
whether that's in his quick reaction
times that help him in catching danger
when it shows up or if it's in his
planning and strategies when it comes to
planning out attacks or defending
himself and his teammates and one thing
is for sure is that all of his training
in video games means that his cognitive
abilities such as spatial navigation
reasoning memory and perception must be
superior at least to a degree and means
that this at the very least could give
him an edge in his problem-solving
skills and in what he's about to face in
this world but even before he met that
guy waking up on what looks to be a
deserted jungle island means that he
should have been way more cautious he
even found that bottle of green tea and
some food but went through it all like
there was no tomorrow what he should
have done was to minimize his
consumption to make his supplies last
longer he even wasted a perfectly good
parachute which you can use for so many
things for one you can use the canopy
which is the large portion of the
parachute it's made from nylon and it
makes a great waterproof lightweight
tent or a bedroll or heck even fishing
lines or possibly even a poncho to wear
and this is not even taking into account
the suspension lines that connect the
harness to the canopy which also could
have been used for countless things
these paracords can usually carry around
up to 550 pounds easily and can be used
as tow lines or to be able to climb
trees or scale walls thanks to its high
tensile strength but somehow despite
sakamoto being the top g in the video
game world is proving to be rather lame
in real life unless he stops acting like
such an idiot he's not gonna survive
much longer the man continues chasing
him and this gamer realizes that he
needs to fight back or he's going to die
recalling his platoon expertise sakamoto
hides from the man and ambushes him
interrogating him on what the hell is
really going on the man laughs in his
face and throws a grenade injuring
sakamoto and forcing him to run away he
surrenders but is attacked again and
thrown off of the cliff face that's when
the glass shard begins to glow just like
the sonar radar in batoon sakamoto
realizes that participants all have
different types of grenades and his
happened to have a timer unlike the man
attacking him he decides to run past the
enemy and jumps into the water the man
laughs thinking that he has sakamoto
cornered suddenly sakamoto's timed bombs
blow up and kill the man instantly
officially turning this wannabe bad ass
into a stone cold killer for real and
he's about to face even deadlier
challenges in the coming days some time
later he finds a pretty girl bathing in
a waterfall and sakamoto chases after
her he runs through the forest and finds
a fat guy taking a crap the fat guy
explains that a plane kidnapped them all
and took around 30 people to an
uninhabited island in the pacific ocean
with no food or water he mentions that
on the plane this guy known as the game
master gave everybody deadly bombs and
told them that the only way to leave
would be to gather seven chips from the
bodies of seven people and the only way
to get these chips would be to kill
someone to get it the fat guy then asks
to team up but sakamoto knows he's
hiding something the man asks to see his
bims but sakamoto realizes that he might
just be playing dumb and refuses to show
him his bombs but agrees to team up okay
now we officially know for sure that
we're in some type of hellish reality
that has us at each other's necks just
like our platoon video game and this
means that the rules of the game apply
and that everybody is officially our
enemy but in this case until we're
better equipped even if it's risky it is
likely to be beneficial for us at least
temporarily if we team up and while they
could use us as bait or screw us over
this will also allow us to do the same
teaming up in this instance means that
we simply need to be on alert because in
actuality just like in man's earlier
days since the dawn of time as time goes
on it is likely that all of our
competitors here will form factions aka
tribes because we're social creatures by
default which means teaming up with
others will give all the other players
here visceral comfort from being in
contact and fellowship with one another
and will allow us to defend against
other rival groups formed in an effort
to pick a winning side and survive at
least to a degree because staying in
groups will be to the benefit of
everyone at least to a point this is
what biologists call a youth sociality
which is the highest level of sociality
and defined by the division of labors
and responsibilities where members will
perform altruistic acts to help benefit
the overall group as a whole if you put
a group of people onto an island and
force them to kill each other it is
likely that many will begin to form
groups whether we like it or not think
of us like ants in a colony because
that's just how humans are designed to
act if we don't join this guy and start
forming our own tribe others will
anyways until we're eventually
outnumbered and outgunned in this
instance the enemy of our enemy is our
friend but i still wouldn't trust this
guy with showing him my bombs because
it's always good to have some tricks up
my sleeve we still don't know what's in
store for us they climb a nearby hill to
see a helicopter dropping off food
rations and head to one of the ration
drop sites sakamoto arrives to see this
lady in the distance who calls dibs then
suddenly a bomb detonates from below and
blows her [ __ ] up sunglasses man here
picks the lady up and takes her chip
bombs and food before running away
shocked sakamoto notices another ration
off in the distance and the two decide
to head over there on the way the two
guys are shocked to see this crazy
looking kid named kosuke next to a dead
corpse not only that the kid didn't pop
up on the radar which makes sakamoto
realize that it only picks up people who
are moving the crew decides to run away
but kosoki is determined to find them
and kill them while running the fat guy
trips like a chump and sprains his ankle
of boo-hoo he tells sakamoto to leave
him behind but the kid decides to lure
kosokei awake and let the fat guy escape
sakamoto uses his sonar to figure out
the boy's location and realizes that he
needs to run towards him to escape his
attack okay this is insane and while
what sakamoto did was sweet as all get
out it was so dumb because he could have
used this opportunity to use the fat
guy's bait and take down kosuke now i
know what i said earlier about forming
tribes but this was loki the real reason
why we kept the fat guy around to use
him as bait because let's face it this
guy is useless and served no real
purpose to us other than moral support
or as bait or distraction sakamoto
should have made a lemonade out of the
situation and use the fat guy but
instead he chose to have a heart also
we've seen how much of a glutton this
fat guy is from the start and we're in a
survival situation keeping him around to
a degree is smart in the long term this
guy will finish our supplies if we let
him if anything i would have tried to
get the best of both worlds and would
have used the fat guy's bait but kill
kosuke before he got onto our fat friend
this way we could have still used him in
some instances of scavenging for drop
points for supplies because after seeing
that lady get blown to all hell he'll
honestly serve a really significant
purpose us using him as a meat shield
for us to get more supplies suddenly
they cross each other's paths and coast
k tosses a big fatty as they land
sakamoto then realizes that this boy is
a high level platoon player and he
continues evading kosuke until the crazy
kid throws an implosion bomb which lands
on his bag suddenly sakamoto quickly
throws the bag into the air as it turns
into dust the kid baits sakamoto into
revealing his location and throws
another grenade his way injured he walks
out of hiding in a daze and looks to the
sky kosuke finds him and throws one more
grenade to finish the job but that's
when sakamoto whips out a bag that
swallows the grenade hole he runs off
and out of the crazy kid's sight
ambushing him from behind with a timer
grenade the kid tries using the sonar to
find him but realizes that sakamoto is
canceling it out by activating his sonar
at the exact same time he catches kosuke
off guard and hits him with a grenade
severely injuring the young kid some
time later they spot a body floating in
a nearby waterfall the man is dead and
has no pants sakamoto gets ready to
leave in case of an enemy attack but the
fat guy tells him that his leg is still
injured and can't walk sakamoto decides
to check out what's going on above the
waterfall and finds another corpse in
the forest he decides to use his sonar
to get a hint of where the enemy could
be and spot this pretty lady from before
standing on top of a cliff suddenly she
throws a grenade off in the wrong
direction but sakamoto quickly realizes
that this is a corrosive gas grenade
meaning it's incredibly toxic okay this
is really really bad this weapon is a
platoon classic and produces a cloud of
highly corrosive gas which literally
disintegrates organic matter in seconds
this basically means that this thing
will melt the weepskin right off of you
and has a lethal radius of between 50 to
100 meters which means that even if this
girl threw the grenade in the wrong
direction they need to get out of there
now because that [ __ ] will still reach
them and while sakamoto could likely
overpower this girl one-on-one she's
packing which means that he needs to
keep his guard up and try to outsmart
her until he can't disarm her now this
situation has proven to us that we can't
kill this girl yet because in actuality
we need her our fat teammate is already
proving to be way more trouble than he's
worth and with his legs still injured
he's not even good enough to use his
bait since he can't even move this means
that we're officially hiring and this
girl is the perfect candidate that we
could use for our business and speaking
of business this grenade is one that we
still have yet to get our fat greasy
paws on and if she refuses to join us we
could just kill her and steal her
grenade stash i'd make finding more of
these class of grenades my number one
priority from here on out sakamoto runs
from the gas and finds himself staring
the girl right in the face he tries to
calm her down by asking her to team up
but she freaks out and throws a grenade
at him he manages to run through the
cloud of smoke and swipes her grenade
but she knocks him over with a stun gun
however sakamoto flips the stun gun back
onto her knocking her out that night her
and the two guys share a meal together
and they explained to her that they're
trustworthy people she tells them that
there's no point of even beating the
death game since someone close to them
in the real world is responsible for
their kidnapping that's when they
realize they've been abandoned by their
friends and family but they're
interrupted when they hear something in
the forest suddenly giant lizards appear
from the shadows the crew try fetching
their stolen bombs but soon find out
that the bombs kosuke gave them aren't
working suddenly someone throws a bomb
onto the fat guy's leg and badly injures
it they continue making their way
through the swamp when suddenly the
komodo dragons reappear and attack them
sakamoto loses sight of the fat guy
ending up in a secluded part of the
forest with absolutely no supplies he
realizes that the fat guy may have just
ditched him and screams out in anger
that's when the komodo dragon attacks
again and a bomb comes up out of nowhere
with the fat guy showing up to save the
day they continue through the forest
feeling the sea breeze and getting
closer to their destination the crew
finds themselves at a ladder and use a
bit of teamwork to bring the girl up
with them however the latter breaks
under their weight and they hear the
komodo dragons coming back oh now we
have komodo dragons chasing us great
this reminds me whenever i hear dom
whining about playing far cry 3 because
just like those damn lizard bastard on
voss's rook island these komodo dragons
are no joke these things can grow to be
over 3 meters long and possess razor
sharp teeth and a poisonous saliva that
can kill a person within hours after a
bite these guys are so badass that they
legit have no natural predators in their
native habitat which means that these
guys are at the top of their food chain
these things move quicker than now aka
bobcat as we call them these things
usually pick their prey apart when it's
solo and not in a group but with an army
of lizards like these after three humans
makes me think that these guys are way
hungrier for food than us now one of the
most effective things we could do is to
run away and keep running since
attacking it head-on with just our fists
is a big fat no-no and we don't want to
waste our bombs and the fact that these
things are capable of only short bursts
of explosive energy up to 21 kilometers
per hour meaning running away from them
in a zigzag pattern will be one of the
best moves to escape these things
because these things can really only run
in a straight-like pattern and utilizing
the trees around us while seemingly safe
is the exact opposite of where we want
to go because while older komodos can't
really climb such things well young
dragons may be nesting within the trees
now because these dragons have followed
us so far makes me think that something
is driving them to us because naturally
komodo dragons only attack if they are
threatened or provoked or smell blood
and this last part is where i think we
have a serious problem because our
friend over here is a dripping
attraction for these blood-seeking
bastards and he's the reason most likely
that these things are continuing to
follow us this means that we need to put
an end to this now and give the people
or this lizard what they want this dude
right here cause to them he's looking
like a thick snack if i was sakamoto i'd
grab a nice rock and smash this guy's
skull in leaving him to the lizards
while we find a way up this rusty piece
of ladder because let's be honest we're
outnumbered outgunned and her only two
teammates are this dude and this chick
and this dude's leg is not getting fixed
any time soon at least not by us and
while we could use this guy's strength
his injury makes him a liability and
also let's be honest if you were a
rambunctious teenager gamer nerd
national champion who would you really
want to save don't lie sakamoto climbs
up the ladder making the fat guy think
that he's leaving the unconscious girl
for death acting quickly sakamoto throws
a corrosive gas grenade at the dragon's
location the fat guy is confused by how
he managed to use the girl's bombs but
sakamoto says that he used the girl's
fingers to touch the button he tells him
that they're safe from the corrosive gas
as well because of the sea breeze that
morning they all wake up safe and sound
but something is wrong with fat guy
suddenly he passes out while crying out
in pain from his injured leg they fetch
some medicine for the man pouring it
onto his leg causing him to pass out
again from the shock later sakamoto
confronts the mysterious girl about how
she's managed to retrieve all of her
supplies he knows that she's killed a
lot of people and would only need to
kill him and fat guy to gather the right
amount of shards to leave the island
suddenly they feel someone used the
sonar and the girl tells him that she'll
leave the crew to go her own way
sakamoto tells her to not leave and
insists that he'll act as a decoy to
fight the incoming enemy my how nice of
him he goes to the forest and scans to
find out if the enemy is near that's
when the mystery man attacks forcing
sakamoto to run off the cliffside he
tries convincing the bandana man to join
his crew but a time her bomb lands next
to him and catches sakamoto off guard
the men hold him hostage but sakamoto
manages to taser mr overalls here and
runs away he goes back to the hideout
but bandana man here follows and demands
that they hand back his supplies the fat
guy tries attacking him from behind but
gets his fingers chopped off in the
process sakamoto rushes towards him but
bandana man easily kicks him off of the
building when he climbs back up he sees
the fat guy writhing about in pain and
the pretty girl is nowhere to be found
noticing her phone on the ground he
takes a look at her wallpaper and
notices a cosplay similar to his virtual
wife in batum kimiko sakamoto finds
himself outside of the enemy hideout and
bandana man knows exactly where he's
going to enter he hides behind a door
and springs out to see mr overalls
instead on the roof sakamoto makes his
entrance and sneaks into the building he
opens this door which is concealing a
hidden bomb and manages to catch it
turning it off and saving himself from
certain death okay we all just saw how
easy it was for bandana man to take us
out this military style trap just proved
to us how prepared our enemy is however
we know a bim bomb becomes the property
of whoever disables it and we've only
got one shot to use it finding the girl
with our radar shouldn't be too much of
an issue however dealing with bandana
man is the problem because even if we
escape we won't get very far but in
every plate of armor there is always a
[ __ ] that we could exploit and his is
mr overalls i would work on taking him
out since he is the easiest to handle
subduing mr ovros will give us access to
his bim bombs i would knock him out and
tie him up using the shoelaces in our
shoes i'd then use his hands to give us
access to his bombs if that plan doesn't
work once he wakes up i threaten him
saying we'll slice off one digit off of
his finger and keep going until we reach
the knuckle by using the makeshift knife
that we made beforehand from the broken
glass in those windows from earlier i
tell him that we'll keep going onto each
finger until he's willing to cooperate i
would force him to transfer ownership of
his bombs to us by making him activate
his bombs one at a time and setting them
with the max amount of time till the
bomb goes off doing this for each one i
would then manually disarm each one
before the countdown expires allowing me
to take control and this process would
take a few minutes since this could take
a bit i would subdue him near a room
with only one exit facing opposite of us
and perhaps a window facing outward with
a ledge to grab onto on the outskirts of
that ledge should we need to escape this
will provide us with one entrance to pay
attention to while we get a hold of mr
overalls bombs should mr bandana man
show up midway and having access to the
windows as a means of escape is super
necessary in case [ __ ] hits the fan and
once we have all of mr overalls bombs
we'll have an edge but i'm not going
near bandana man in close quarters once
we have more than enough imps we'll be
able to take out bandana man with ease
walking inside the room he finds the
girl tied up on a bed sakamoto frees her
and asks if she happened to play the
character of himiko in batum she says no
but sakamoto decides to call her by the
name anyway meanwhile the bad guy
realizes that their hostage has just
been taken away mr overalls runs after
them seeing glimpses of sakamoto trying
to escape suddenly the bad guy runs into
a trap set up by sakamoto but bandana
man here has himiko in his grip
bandanaman challenges sakamoto to a
fistfight but he's not interested
sakamoto runs out of cover grabbing a
knife trying to stab the man he's pushed
away and the man pins him to the ground
kimiko jumps on him but is instantly
thrown off that's when bandanaman
realizes that she's triggered a gas bomb
attached to his chest the two run off
and climb out of the building leaving
bandana man for dead that night they
decide to rest up in the enemy's hideout
before meeting up with the fat guy when
they're sleeping himiko notices a
ghost-like figure staring at her she
freaks out and is certain that it wasn't
her imagination sakamoto takes her to
look for the ghost and finds a strange
room that looks lived in suddenly a
hatchet-wielding woman attacks him from
behind but sakamoto knocks her out and
realizes that she's missing an arm when
the ghost lady wakes up she tells himiko
here to not trust men but she tells that
sakamoto is different the ghost lady
explains that she was a nurse in her
past life and tampered with some medical
records to protect an unlawful doctor
however the doctor betrayed her and put
the blame onto the ghost lady she
continues by saying that both her and
the doctor were sent to the island
making it to the very end of the game
together when the time came to leave the
doctor betrayed her one final time
blowing off her arm and leaving the
ghost lady for dead she tells them that
once someone gathers the right amount of
shards a helicopter lands and takes them
away to safety sakamoto and himiko
discuss outside the possibility of
hijacking one when this happens but
himiko here is hiding a very important
detail okay this ghost lady is batshit
crazy and looks the part to back it up
but she just told us a valuable piece of
info probably the most important thing
that we've ever received because we
already knew that we needed a certain
amount of crystals to leave the island
but now we know the exact method by
which they'll rescue us and with this we
can use it to prepare ourselves for when
we get rescued the island seems to have
characteristics of what is known as an
oceanic island aka a volcanic island
this type of island is formed by
eruptions of volcanoes on the ocean
floor and this island flora consists of
thousands of tropical trees and that
means that there's enough cover for us
to be able to spot a helicopter
approaching without us being spotted
however at this point we don't know for
sure if the metric by which the game
master decides who is to be rescued is
solely based on the bio indicators
placed within our bodies or if that is
supplemented by surveillance scattered
throughout the island because it is very
likely that there are cameras placed
everywhere which means we won't be able
to do anything suspicious yet to
outsmart them for now we should continue
our mission with killing enough people
to warrant the game master sending a
rescue helicopter however knowing this i
would have the gang prepare for when
that time comes as of now it seems
highly inefficient that the only way
this game rescues its members is by
helicopter because who's to say that
would stop other members from trying to
take advantage of this and perhaps even
trying to ambush the helicopter when it
arrives i would try and make a ghost
lady recall every small detail of her
story first noting what gear and
security detail that the helicopter had
on them when they arrived including any
weapons as well as the location of where
it landed when it came to rescue them
whether that was in the exact location
of where they were or nearby at a
certain draw point more favorable to a
landing helicopter because these details
will matter and will allow us to better
prepare for when we have enough crystals
to warrant a rescue team coming for us
and knowing how to prepare for it will
allow us to figure out a way to take
advantage of it when they arrive back at
the old hideout they find that the fat
guy is being treated by a mystery man he
tells them that he's a doctor and that
he doesn't want to take part in the
death game sakamoto checks his bombs and
sees that he's not even used it even
once they forgive him for being
suspicious and agree to work together
yeah great move that's when they notice
a supply drop nearby and head out to go
fetch supplies sakamoto runs towards it
and runs into sunglasses guy once again
they throw bombs at each other and
sakamoto is injured in the blast he
notices sunglasses guy throw a corrosive
gas grenade at the doctor and tells him
to run sakamoto manages to catch the
trunk of food and runs away before being
trapped by a flame bomb sunglasses guy
tackles him and takes the trunk before
sakamoto's blown off of the cliff and
into the ocean he swims behind a rock
noticing another shady man coming out of
the forest the man finds the trunk of
food and goes over to steal it suddenly
a trap grenade activates and kills him
on the spot sunglasses guy takes the
trunk but sakamoto surprises him from
behind threatening to blow him up the
guy surrenders putting all of his
belongings onto the ground sakamoto
knows this guy's bluffing but he doesn't
know what he's up to and tells him to
turn around but he doesn't but sakamoto
thinks his buddies are close by and
ignores this when he walks over to the
trunk sunglasses guy activates a remote
bomb however sakamoto manages to avoid
being blown up okay it's one thing to
not know what someone is capable of in a
place like this but this kid clearly
knew what sunglasses guy was capable of
since he literally saw him do some crazy
[ __ ] before sunglasses guy isn't your
average player he is cunning and is
prone to using traps to get his way as
we saw earlier sakamoto had no excuses
and should not have rushed to get his
loot this almost cost him his life and
having him back away from his loot by
itself was not enough to ensure that he
didn't have any dirty tricks up his leaf
sakamoto could have been a little less
stupid and at the very least could have
ordered sunglasses guy to turn around
and give us a spin seriously this would
have taken two seconds and judging from
the fact that the detonator was in this
guy's mouth means that this was a rookie
mistake on sakamoto's part especially
since sunglasses guy ignored sakamoto
when he told him to turn around which i
don't know about you but that would be a
major red flag sunglasses guy walks off
into the forest and koseke reappears
telling him that he took all of the
supplies and the whole thing was a
failure back at the hideout they try
feeding the fat guy whatever food they
have left but the doctor mentions that
they need to get rid of the lizard
poison within him or he'll die sakamoto
and himiko tell the duck that they know
a spa to find medicine where ghost lady
was staying and once there the doctor
finds and fills a trunk full of medical
goodies giving it to sakamoto to keep
but just then himiko comes running and
telling him that there's a bomb inside
that trunk right before it goes off this
dock is a full-on baddie and threatens
to kill himiko but that's when ghost
lady appears and stabs him she then
takes himiko away and they find out that
the doc has planted bombs all over the
building just then the doc comes back
injured as hell and she throws a bomb at
him but not before he activates another
bomb that flings her off of the building
he goes back inside to take out himiko
when a grenade he throws bounces off of
her boobs suddenly sakamoto comes back
from the dead and chases him down and
then he activates another remote bomb
and accidentally injures himself and
falls to the ground the ghost a lady
tells the young ones to step aside but
she doesn't have the guts to finish the
job with the medicine acquired and the
older couple reunited under strange
circumstances sakamoto and himko decide
to go back to the old hideout that's
when he hears something strange at the
distance a homing bomb suddenly chases
him around brutally injuring his leg the
two instantly realize that the fat guy
has finally betrayed them they hear
another homing bomb come their way and
himiko grabs it turning it off before it
explodes they try to chase him down but
the fat guy thinks they're out for
revenge sakamoto screams out that he
wants to apologize but that's when the
fat guy is cornered by a group of
lizards he decides to detonate the bomb
on himself to take out the reptiles
leaving sakamoto and himiko all by
themselves that night himiko tells him
to kill her if he does he'll have enough
shards to beat the game and leave the
island but sakamoto refuses like the
horned up good boy that he is telling
her that he'll only leave the island
once they both have enough shards ending
this adventure just like the film
predators with them no closer to getting
home and more [ __ ] about to head their
way howdy do everybody griffin here from
how to beat anime what did you think
about batoon what did you like about it
what you didn't like about it let us
know don't forget to like comment
subscribe and as always don't forget to
check out our how to be playlist